so what we're doing in San Diego San
Diego State so you went okay so you were
an Aztec as well and then I transferred
to USC ah you're just all over
California you're the queen of
California thank you do you ever make it
over to Tijuana for good Mexican food
when you live there honest
I was I would be scared
because I would hear the stories and you
know
it's crazy but I'm like you know that
ain't my hood it's like trying to go
downstairs
I like my life you know I always like
equate it like if you hear about stuff
like you hear about the worst about a
place on the news it'd be like someone
who's from like
Massachusetts visiting LA and thinking
they're going to get robbed or like
banged on like it might happen that's
Tijuana
nah I think
TJ's lit they got great like okay if I
go down there with like you and some
other people that know the area then
yeah but I'm just not going yeah
really the dentist was fire and uh
oysters I get like a dozen oysters for
like eight dollars
you're like like seafood's your main
your main [ __ ] what's your like favorite
food oh I love me some seafood a seafood
boil
um some spicy sauce lemon butter do you
cook yeah I cook what's like your if I
if someone were to put you on like a
competition show a seafood pasta that's
your main go-to seafood pasta I don't
eat meat no more but I can make a good
steak
why not what why no meat
um in February I was working a lot and
my body felt like it just kept breaking
down so I was like how do I just remove
something from my diet right um to
improve my health right and I thought
that honestly I didn't think that I was
going to be able to do it but after it
became a habit I kind of just forgot
about meat and then like a month ago I
tried eating um
a huevos Ranchero burrito with some beef
in it and it tastes hella good but when
I tell you my body rejected it in 10
seconds I had to like ran to the
bathroom you had to blow it up
I didn't blow it up it kind of
came back out the other way
so you puked huh you puked I puked I
puked last night yeah this is not fun
and this morning oh yeah this morning
yeah I did what color was it uh this
morning it was just clear it was like I
was just puking up tequila oh that's
good yeah it was like it was like
something just turned out a water hose
it was [ __ ] up you know what makes a
really safe puke Gatorade
so if you know you're going to puke will
you drink the Gatorade drink hella
Gatorade because you're like I might as
well just keep the Gatorade out it keeps
the burn away for some reason nice
you've had some some you got some
experience you gotta work in the morning
[ __ ]
how do you cook your steak you say you
make a good steak what do you do the
cast iron pan like we put it in the oven
how are you making your steak so I like
some I like fruits like marinate okay
you know with the beer the seasoning
whatever in the refrigerator for a
little bit and then I like to bake it
and then once it's done I like to grill
it to like crisp the sides yeah you
gotta sear it there it is oh yeah you're
a real one I learned from my dad shout
out to your pops